well after crunching the numbers we can
officially announce eddie wu is
australia's favorite maths teacher first
finding fame on his
woo tube channel the educator fast
multiplied his success
with 80 million views online inspiring
kids and adults
to get excited about the subject
i love that maths helps us understand
and wonder at the world around us in a
deeper way than we could otherwise
it's really about taking what i love and
just saying you know what
if we put that on a platform that can
access the world
there's no limit to what we can achieve
despite it making us feel stupid we love
eddie now the
australian local hero has put pen to
grid paper sharing his life story
in a brand new biography aimed at
pint-sized
readers he's proving that following your
dreams is just as important as your
abc's and your one two three
eddie wu joins us live and show we love
having you in here hi everybody
kylie larry thanks for having me back a
pleasure let's just talk about 2020 just
really quickly
you're one of the first teachers to take
your classes online which
now has proved to be like you're ahead
of the game
adapting very easily did you it was
something which i was
really delighted to be feeling like i'd
involuntarily been preparing for for
several years
speaking to a camera and having to
interact my students uh
online rather than face to face we
definitely miss being in the classroom
so much and
grateful to be back there now um but it
was something where
every teacher really had to reinvent the
book almost overnight when we all went
into lockdown
so you were okay with that but what
about the other teachers who who weren't
used to using that medium and and
relating to kids like that
how did that go do you think yeah steep
learning curve for sure though i do
think i
i think we've learned so much from that
even though it was a very violent kind
of all right we're doing this
i wasn't joking about overnight it was a
very sudden change where you might
remember your kids kind of like right
we're all going home now um i think that
we've learned tremendous things about
how to
help our students and support them in
remote ways that we can now keep on
doing even when we're back in the
classroom
there's a draft a new national
curriculum expected later this month
now there are concerns the current
system under the current system
on average 15 year old australians are
three and a half years behind students
in china
what do you think should be included in
the new curriculum where does it need a
little tickle up eddie
it's really tricky to think about this
because curriculum documents
are something which teachers and
students all used to think about what
are we supposed to teach what are we
supposed to learn
but it is really different to say what's
in a curriculum document
versus what are we actually doing with
our kids in the classroom what's their
daily experience like there's always a
bit of a gap between there so
in terms of you know changes that are
happening at the moment i think it's
really wonderful that there's a renewed
focus on
problem solving yeah reason those are
really valuable we want our kids to be
able to do that
but at the same time i i think we need
to be careful about say the
international benchmarking that compares
us with
countries around the world oecd there's
only so many things that can come
through
on fairly narrow assessments like that
so we always need to take that with a
grain of salt
but parents love those parents love
those graphs don't they and those
survey results now it's just not what
our kids learn but how they learn
and you have this second woo tube
channel dedicated to teaching
teachers so what's your advice up to
creating an engaging lesson
for your students your teacher students
yeah i do remember the first time that i
thought to myself
wow these student teachers who i'm now
meeting in uh
in in my school as a as a teacher trying
to mentor them
i thought wow these guys are just kids
and that that's when i realized oh i'm
in this next generation
i have a responsibility yes you're old
now yeah that's
thanks it was a very euphemistic day but
for me you know when you asked about
what advice do i give for helping
teachers be engaging
to like you said our kids really knowing
our students well knowing what makes
them tick what interests them
and being able to connect what i'm
teaching to the things that drive them
motivate them that's really the key
now here uh tell us about this new
biography and there's sort of these
stories
aimed at kids who were just like you at
school
tell us about your experience at school
and why you think it's important you've
put it in this book
yeah so this is a little bit different
to books i've been involved with
in the past in that like you said it's a
bit more biographical so it goes all the
way back from
my early life and tells the story of how
i came to where i'm now speaking with
you
and i think that maybe answers the
question in terms of why
is it valuable for um children to hear
the stories of how people
like uh myself or you know mundane
moderates the surgeon
or uh georgia ward fear the reptile
biologist how do they get to
where they are now often was through
through challenge difficulties but
you're saying it wasn't cool
to be the kid who was good at maths at
school well
wasn't cool and also wasn't necessarily
where i came from so
being able to embrace that struggle and
to know we don't just you know
pop out and here we are instantly we are
gifted and skilled
that comes through a real uh journey of
challenge and being able to overcome
those difficulties so there's also
uh in the series also shares the stories
of some other
stem stars who else has been included
yeah so i mentioned uh
munzett and georgia before you've got
say for example fiona wood who's the
inventor of
spray on skin so particularly helpful
with burn victims
and to know her story of innovation um
and to know all of the
challenges there that she overcame and
the life and death situations
that she had to wrestle with for me such
an inspiring story so eddie you're
hoping some little
10 year old or 11 year old boy or girl
reads your story and goes you know what
i i love i love maths and maybe i could
make a go of this and make it into a
career
or it could lead me somewhere else yeah
i mean it's really hard for children to
be something that they can't see first
and
you know for example um gizly kaplan who
is a burden primate specialist um her
story of
you know coming to australia and the
journey she's been through i hope
encourages inspires many people out
there as well yeah and as you said
earlier i mean there might be someone
watching this who thinks one day
i can be on the morning show we can all
aspire to see if
i study hard and write all these books
and change the world one day
i'll be there with kylie and whoever
else is hosting when that guy's dead
good to see you mate as always you can
pick up a copy of the new book eddie woo
superstar maths teacher part of the
aussie stem
stars series it's out now one of our
favorite guests thank you mate just
ahead is the art of haggling
dead by more aussies than ever are
missing out on bargains
and